we have Ramsey solutions bud and
annalisa are with us hey guys how are
you good good welcome here to do it that
free scream I know I love it I love it
where are you from
oh cool welcome it's so good to have you
guys so how much dad have you paid off
we paid off one hundred and twenty four
thousand two hundred and twenty dollars
in 24 months I love it very good making
what kind of money well we started out
2014 or 2013 making forty three thousand
what I filed taxes on and next year we
combined incomes after getting married
and combined about one hundred and seven
and this year were projected to make
around a one hundred ninety good
gracious
to go yeah you changed your life in the
last three years
yeah what in the world what do you do
for a living well I'm a pharmacist and
buds an engineer oh okay and so the we I
graduated in 2013 and started a half a
year was work and then she graduated
2014 I got you okay so this is kicking
into two solid professional careers and
it took when both of them hit that's
when this kick yeah that makes sense
well congratulations thank you a great
job man this is incredible
how old are you - 26 26 and you're
making 200 grand a year yeah Wow
so I'm guessing a hundred and twenty
four thousand with an engineer and a
pharmacist might have had some student
loans well but had also includes our
house you know just go ahead and do that
while you're like 26,000 but the student
loans were about 98 gotcha so what's the
house worth probably 30 35 okay so it's
a it's a starter house yeah at the
typical doctor house I guess I'm saying
okay well now you've got the tour income
you'll be able to save and move up
pretty quickly that's the goal pay cash
absolutely oh yeah you'll be able to
because two years is what
so so how much will you save in two
years we're hoping by around $150,000
house or so some something is to kind of
a midterm house and our long-term goals
to buy a bunch of property and build a
house yeah that's a good ways down the
road if we're paying cash well you'll be
able to do that with this kind of income
and then living in $150,000 budget in
Evansville it's a great house oh yeah
for that you know excellent way to go
you guys man so you got married and this
whole thing started then it was a little
bit before about my junior college I was
talking to my mom and I bought some
money from her and we kind of had to add
my student loans up and I never really
paid much attention till then and we I
was expecting maybe 40 or 50 thousand
and we added them up and it was around
70 or 75 and I didn't even know what to
think and so about senior year we came
through and I started just randomly
listening to your show at work and and
there wasn't much to do at that point
but just kind of save and I'd already
taken out I'd already done the damage on
my student loans so her dad actually
bought me financial peace as a
graduation present so I went through
with him the first time and walking the
play we're gonna plan myself and then we
got married and just before getting
married we took it together also so very
good so how'd you get through school
debt-free um well my parents have
followed your playing my whole life
oh I grew up like that and they saved up
for me and my brother both did Wow so
they saved up and paid for college they
did like that seven years in a doctorate
degree Wow amazing
that's excellent what a wonderful gift
yeah and and they did that they've been
listening to me apparently a long long
as as far as I can remember back yeah me
and my brother grew up on the envelopes
and the Commission's and the whole thing
Wow Wow
and here you sit stand completely
successful wow I'm impressed
very very cool you guys sharp young
gonna have so much money you're gonna be
able to help so many people will be so
generous and and haven't just an
incredible life yeah
the nation if both of your parents have
laid and knowledge into you and how they
plowed into you and got you going and
then you that you're smart enough to
work hard and be frugal and I mean not a
lot of pharmacists move into a $30,000
things for me I told but it was hard to
stay motivated cuz all my friends went
out bought new cars big houses you know
they're always posting pictures of it
and stuff and here we are in our little
one-bedroom walk-in closet that's great
well it was worth a hundred thousand or
not so what do you tell people the key
is because you guys have really you've
really leaned into this I mean it's
pretty amazing what do you tell them the
key to getting out of debt because we
got 26 year olds listening with $100,000
in student loan debt out all over the
place out there yeah I would say that
it's possible I feel like a lot of my
friends that are in the same position
they they just talk about it like it's
normal and that you know that's just
what it is but I don't think they
realize that if they stay motivated and
work hard for it that it's completely
possible
yeah yeah just staying motivated the
whole time and the coolest thing of the
whole story and you guys haven't seen
this yet I'm the old guy so I get to see
it all the time but the if you learn to
do something this intense in concert
with each other as one of the first
things in your marriage it sets you up
you guys when you learn to work together
like that you can do anything yeah
anything that comes at you if you'll do
the same thing and just get at it
together you can do it I mean you set
your marriage on a path that's
incredible
yeah so that's what everybody told us
coming through a financial piece was
that they they all wish that they would
have started it whenever they got
married yeah I say the same thing I said
I wish I would have started in high
school but hey it worked out it did it
did so way to go you two very proud of
you
gives us hope all right but it annalisa
Evansville Indiana a hundred and twenty
four thousand dollars paid off in 24
months making forty three all the way up
to one hundred and ninety living in a
paid for thirty thousand dollar house
let's hear a debt free scream alright
three absolutely awesome man that's fun